the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
she has three full-grown dragons yoga is
the same as egg on when he conquered the
Seven Kingdoms how do you propose to
stop them
we are currently at work on a solution
my lord
apparently one of the nearest dragons
was wounded by Spears in the fighting
pits of Meereen they can be wounded they
can be killed finest art elitism
blacksmiths in King's Landing have been
labouring day and night degrees what's
up ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another game of Thorin season eight in
Game Theory's video as I'm sure most of
you know by now I recently uploaded a
video about one of the plot leaks for
the final season and I noticed there
were a few comments asking me about
Cersei Lannister and the golden company
I did make a video about them several
months ago but not too many people saw
that video for whatever reason so I
figured this would be a good opportunity
for me to discuss some other potential
outcomes instead of repeating what other
youtubers have already said let's take
this in a completely different direction
most people assume the golden company
will break their contract with Cersei by
joining forces with the Targaryen x' but
what if that doesn't happen as of right
now everyone should already know Circe's
plan for next season or at least what
she told Jaime Cersei told Jaime she has
no intentions of helping Jon and
Daenerys defeat the army of the dead she
told everyone she would send all of her
banners north but we all know that was a
lie Cersei is actually sending euron
greyjoy to Essos to pick up the golden
company based on what we've been told
she could be receiving around 20,000
soldiers along with elephants trained
for battle after Cersei lost so many men
during the field of fire this is exactly
what she needs to be able to put up some
kind of a respectable fight next season
thanks to the tyro gold Cersei was able
to pay off the iron bank and start a new
line of credit which allowed her to pull
this off but almost everyone is
expecting the golden company to break
their contract even though they're known
for never breaking a contract if you've
read the books then you would know there
is an example of this happening so
perhaps the television show plans to do
the same thing but I don't want to go
down that same road I wanted to explore
some different options because there is
always that chance the golden company
could support Cersei until the very
not to mention there was no evidence of
the golden company breaking their
contract during the filming of the final
season plenty of photos and videos
leaked from the set and I did not notice
any sign of the golden company switching
sides so just for the sake of this video
let's assume they will stick to their
word there was one part of the plot
league that could actually work and if
Cersei was able to pull this off it
would be genius so according to this
plot league
it says Cersei and Qyburn come up with a
plan at the very beginning of the season
it says Cersei will go to Qyburn and
tell him to enlist all the best
blacksmiths from King's Landing in order
to start mass producing as many
scorpions as possible just in case you
forgot what a scorpion is it's the
biggest looking crossbow Brown used to
shoot down drug on now that Cersei paid
off the iron bank I really don't see her
having a problem with getting the money
to start producing multiple scorpions so
far this would be a great idea this is
something Cersei and Qyburn should have
done already and perhaps Qyburn is
already doing this and we just don't
know about it yet he did have the first
scorpion made without our knowledge so I
would not be surprised if there are a
more next season you have to think about
it like this the more scorpions you have
the more chances you can have at
bringing down a dragon imagine if Cersei
had a dozen of these made and they were
able to fire them all at the same time
how the hell would Daenerys be able to
dodge a dozen different scorpion bolts
coming in all directions I don't think
she would be able to at the beginning of
next season the news about the night
King taken down the wall will start to
spread throughout Westeros the entire
continent will have to be put on high
alert because of the night King and his
army of the Dead are now heading south
with a dragon and Giants believe it or
not this can actually benefit Circe's
plan as of right now we all know Cersei
has no intentions of helping John or
Daenerys with this fight but it could
actually benefit her if she does send
some help instead and I'll tell you why
when an if Jaime Lannister arrives in
Winterfell I'm assuming he will tell
them sir she lied about helping them
however once sir she finds out the night
king is actually heading south with a
dragon she could lie again but she could
send them help at the same time once
Cersei receives this news she can
immediately send word to Winterfell and
apologize for not helping
could say that she's sorry for not
taking them serious but now that she
knows the night king is actually a
threat she can send them as much help as
possible or as much help that benefits
her secret plan she can tell them she
will send the remaining Lannister troops
along with the golden company she
purchased as reinforcements but I will
also be sending them with about a dozen
scorpions because of the night King now
has a dragon this will help all of us to
bring down his dragon as soon as
possible John and Daenerys might not
want to believe her at first
but they really aren't in any position
to start turning down some help and we
all know John is always ready to give
someone a second or third chance if John
gets the sense that the night King might
be coming to Winterfell with this family
there he would definitely accept Cersei
second offer ultimately they would
probably agree to this because there
aren't gonna have too much time to sit
around and debate anyway with the night
king heading their way they will need to
act fast once they agree to these terms
all Cersei needs to do is make sure she
has Lannister men only controlling the
scorpions people that she think she can
trust now that Jaime left
Cersei will need to find a new commander
along with a handful of other men that
can be her top lieutenants now in order
for Cersei to gain their trust she's
gonna have to promise them everything
under the Sun castles titles highborn
wives some new land whatever it takes
for them to carry out her plans
I'm sure she can find plenty of men who
would love to have a castle of their own
she needs to make one thing very clear
and this is what should actually
convince Jon and Daenerys that Cersei
might actually be telling the truth
especially when they see it with their
own eyes
Cersei should hold a small council
meeting with these few select men and
tell them to go north with the scorpions
and actually help defeat the night king
Cersei may or may not want to admit this
but she actually needs the night king to
lose as soon as possible
Cersei says she wants the army of the
Dead to help defeat our enemies in the
north but if this were to happen Cersei
would be screwed because the night king
would then just raise up all of those
dead soldiers in the north then come
down to King's Landing and completely
obliterated Cersei would not stand a
chance so she actually needs the night
King to lose so Cersei must tell these
men to make sure the night king is
defeated first use the Scorpions to take
down his dragon once Jonathan arrows
wits
see Circe's men trying to take down the
night king's dragon they would pretty
much be convinced that Cersei is
honoring her commitment however this is
where Circe's plan could unfold once the
night king and his dragon are brought
down that's when the men controlling the
scorpions would immediately point them
at Danny's dragon and begin to fire they
would be completely blindsided by this
and if Sir sees men acted fast they
could take down both at Annie's dragons
before anyone would even have time to
react during this chaos they would never
see it coming
Cersei could potentially kill two birds
with one stone if her plan could play
out perfectly John and Daenerys would
have no reason to be suspicious because
they would see Lannister men and men
from the golden company fighting side by
side with their men and dying right
alongside their own men as they tried to
defeat the army of the dead plus they
would all see all the Scorpions pointed
at the night Kings dragon but that's
until they bring down the night king and
Viserion
and once that happened all hell would
break loose Cersei would obviously lose
a lot of men but so would John and
Daenerys but if Cersei was able to bring
down all the dragons it would almost
level the playing field the battle
against the night king would be so
intense they would be completely caught
off guard if Cersei done something like
this if she had a dozen scorpions all
firing at the same time you could bring
down a dragon very fast before they even
knew what hit them
when Circe's men would show up with
these scorpions the best thing for them
to do is to go to John right away and
ask him what type of projectiles they
would need to make to bring down the
night Kings dragon this would put Dany
and John's minds at ease right away if
they thought they were only worried
about making projectiles that took down
an undead dragon John knows what it
takes to kill white son White Walkers so
he would probably have them make giant
arrow tips at a dragon class and they
could even make some of the arrows
shafts out of small where would branches
we all know how special those trees are
so they might also contain the type of
magic that can stop soldiers or animals
in the army of the dead if he had a
dozen scorpions all shooting dragon
glass arrows at Viserion at the same
time I'm sure it would bring his ass
down pretty quick then once the dragon
slams into the ground that's when John
or whoever needs the challenge of the
night King to a sword fight then take
his ass down for good and if beric
Dondarrion is correct then killing the
night king
could cause his entire army to fall to
the ground if that happened Daenerys
would land her dragons assuming the
fight is over but during the confusion
all the scorpions would then turn to
Daenerys and her dragons and if they're
stationary targets it's game over by the
time John and Daenerys realized what is
even happening it would already be too
late
not only would all of the scorpions have
already fired a shot simultaneously but
they could be getting reloaded and fired
again by the time they realized that
their even being fired upon all of
Circe's men that are still alive would
then of course turn their blades onto
John and Danny's forces most of them
could kill at least one person by the
time they realized what was happening
even if Cersei lost most of her men or
all of her men she would have already
delivered a blow so devastating Daenerys
would probably never recover from it
imagine how shocking it would be as
Cersei actually pulled something like
this off the army of the Dead and all
three dragons could be taken out at
pretty much the same time it would
almost be like the red wedding but
instead of it happening in a dining hall
it would be happening on the battlefield
now well Game of Thrones actually do
something like this probably not but I
wanted to explore a different scenario
instead of just making another video
about the golden company breaking their
contract anyways let me know what you
think about this idea it's definitely
not something I would bet on but it's
fun to discuss it either way put your
thoughts or questions down below in the
comment section I want to thank everyone
for watching today's video I really
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel for another month
thank you all so much I hope you have a
great day and I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you